well under normal circumstances in a
sane country whose leaders didn't hate
it the people in charge would condemn
this kind of unrest the cops would round
up the people vandalizing public
property that belongs to all of us and
arrest those who are stealing subway
rides order would be restored life will
go on people would pay their 275 to ride
the subway but this is America in 2019
so any move that almost perfectly
embodies the absurdity of our current
political moment congresswoman
Alexandria Kazuya Cortez came out in
favor of the riot that trace just
described punch a cop she's for that
standards have shifted a lot in America
so it's hard to be surprised daily by
anything anymore but a lawmaker
suggesting that law enforcement quote
destabilizes our community in signing
with people who want to punch a cop you
wonder about that you wonder if in the
name of stabilizing her community
alexandria Acacio cortez would support a
full NYPD withdraw from her
congressional district or maybe around
the upscale apartment building that she
lives in here in Washington Joe Murray
is a retired NYPD police officer he's
running for District Attorney in Queens
and joins us tonight mr. morri thanks so
much for coming on punch a cop what do
you make of a sitting member of Congress
endorsing the punch of cop movement it's
disgusting
I'm all for the First Amendment I I
think people should express themselves
but when you're talking about
encouraging people to commit crimes
particularly striking police officers
that's outrageous so you're a debt
you're a Democrat I am a Democrat yeah
more conservative Democrat my most of my
family's involved in unions and labor
and that's our core democratic
principles come from but I am very
conservative and a law-and-order guy and
in Queens County I am the law and order
candidate fighting against Melinda Katz
who's the borough president who's
endorsed all of this progressive
criminal justice reform that mayor de
Blasio has been trying to ran down our
throats yeah I mean this doesn't seem
like reform like what what happens when
lawmakers like Alexandria Kazuya Cortes
encourage people to quote punch a cop
like where does that wind up it's
anarchy that's where we're going with
this I mean we have a social contract
that we as the citizens have elected
officials who enact laws and then we
elect our chief executives to enforce
the laws this is the social contract
that civilization is based on when you
now just want to do away with that and
make your own rules and live lawlessly
and encourage that behavior that's
anarchy but it's it's absolutely insane
so if you have a lawmaker and their air
quotes around that endorsing violence
against people enforcing the law then it
doesn't take too long before things fall
completely apart right it really is I
mean I look especially growing up I
looked at public officials particularly
our our congressional representatives
and and federal officers as role models
like this is the standard that we look
for this is not what we want our kids to
look at and emulate so Alexander Kazi
Cortez lives and predictably of course
she does lives in a rich neighborhood
here in Washington like one of the
richest actually but I wonder do you
think that she applies the same
standards to our own neighborhood do you
think she'd like all the cops to leave
tomorrow absolutely not
absolutely 9:00 you know that talker I
mean this is all about what's happening
here in Brooklyn but not around her
neighborhood I mean clearly that's the
standard yeah so I bet you know she's
for gun control but I bet she's happy
that her bodyguards have guns right I
think that that's true absolutely I just
can't wait I have a dear friend John
Cummings and other retired police
officer who's going to be running
against AOC so I'm looking forward to
that John and I talk all the time
hopefully I'll be successful in my race
in Queens County then having John take
her spot will start to make some changes
I mean and just last question since you
were a cop for a long time like in the
end it is poor people who bear the brunt
of this right so when cops can't enforce
the law rich people like Alexandria Kazi
court is like she's fine but the people
in her district how do they fare exactly
now the people she's encouraging to act
like
this in this behavior what's gonna
happen to that while she goes off the
Starbucks with her friends and and
hanging out they're the ones that are
gonna suffer from this so it's just poor
choices on her part all the way around
poor judgment
yeah well she's dumb she like to think
she doesn't know what she's saying but
this is going too far I think there's
great to see you then Joe thanks so much
thank you I appreciate it